それでこの今までのところはこの
何さんでしたっけ このカーラティーマカットという人のお寺でたくさん
人 比丘たちが住むように用意しているのにいて
それからお釈迦様がこのガタという人のお寺に
その人が寄付しているお寺に行ったら
すごい大勢の人々 坊さんたちがビール飲んでるんです
そこで何でしょうかと聞いたら
今仕事を真っ最中ということで
これも作ってるんだと
お釈迦様は王政の人々を集めて
大型でいろんな仕事をして
話したり いろんなことをしてる人にはあまり賛成しなかったんですね
そんなことをしたら この修行はできなくなるんだと
人々と仲良く仕事をしたり
話したり 喋ったり 世間話をしたりしちゃうと
サマーディも得られないんだよと
ですから このまあ 物事をあまり観察しないで行った方がいいということをお釈迦様は説明してあったんですね
今日はそこからです
アヤンコーパナ アナンダ ヴィハーロ タターガテーナ アビサンブッロ ヤディダン サッバ ニミッターナン アマネスカ
ーラ アッジャッタン スンニャッタン ウパサンパッジャ ヴィハリトゥン タット ワチェーヤアナンダ タタ
ーガタン イミナ ヴィハーレナ ヴィハランタン バヴァンティ ウパサンカミターロ ビククー ビククニーヨ ウパサー
カ ウパシーカヨー ラージャーノ ラージャ マハマッター ティッティヤーティッティヤ サーヴァカー
タトラ アナンダ タターガタヴィヴェカ ニンネーワ チッテーナ ヴィヴェカ ポンネーナ ヴィヴェカ パンバーレーナ
ルーパ カッテーナ ニッカンマー ビラテーナ ビャンティ ブーテーナ サッバ ソーヴァーサワッターニーイエ ヒ
ダンミーヒ アンニャ ダットゥ ウッヨージニーヤ パティサンユッターン エーワ カタング カッター ホーティー
そこまで文章部ですけど
アヤンコーパナ アナンダ ヴィハーロ タターガテーナ アビサンブッロ
アヤンコーパナ ヴィハーロ
このようなヴィハーロっていうのは住むということで
生活すること 生きていること
このような生き方がありますと
それは タターガテーナ アビサンブッロ
タターガタというのはお釈迦様のことで
如来に悟られた 如来が悟られた
このある生き方があるんだよと
それはどんな生き方かと
ヤディダン どのような生き方というと
というところで サッバ ニミッターナン アマネスカーラ
サッバ ニミッターナン
すべての対象を認識しない
心に入れておかない 一切の対象は
対象は三つですけど 眼耳鼻舌身意に入る色声香味触法というふうに
この六つですけどね それを心に入れてあげない
余計な説明をしちゃうとあまり良くないですから
一応 六つの対象っていうのは
目に形が入ることで 目ではもう何も受け取れないことにする
耳に音を入ることが2番目
それも受け取らない 心で受け取らないことにする
鼻で香りを感じたりしますね
それも受け取らないことにします
で 舌で味を感じること
そこでストップする 体で感じますね
痛みやらいろんなもの
体があるという感覚がありますね
寒いとか そういう体でも
もう体に入る情報も取らないことにする
それが頭の中でいろんな思考
概念が回転するんですね
その機能も心の機能もストップする
何も認識しないということにするんだ
それで生きてるっていうことは認識することなんです
生きてるんだっていうことは
何か見たり 聞いたり 感じたり
考えたりすることが生きていることなんですね
感情をいろいろ作ったりしてね
それは生きているということ
これは出世間の境地で
それをそういうことあるんだぞとお釈迦様が悟りましたね
もう我々の言葉で言えば
もう生きてない状態なんですね
もう何も認識しないということに
アマニシカーラ アッジャッタン スンニャッタン ウパサンパッジャ ヴィハルティ
そこでその じゃあいろんなことを認識していた心はどうなっているんでしょうか？もう何も認識していないんだから
もう心の状態は苦という状態ですね
何一つも現象たるものを認識しない
その認識しないということで
心は苦という状態になってしまうんだよ
で それはお釈迦様の心の境地なんです
タトラ チェ アーナンダ タターガタン イミナー ヴィハーレーナ ヴィハランタン
タトラ チェ そこでアーナンダよ
タターガタン 如来が イミナー ヴィハーレーナ
このような生き方をしていると
それはもうまるっきり人には理解できない生き方やと思いますけど
何も認識しない生き方をしている
心も回転しないっていう
回転というか 心でもいろいろ概念
何も回転しない 感情もない
何も認識しない なんかこんな感じですね
例えばこの もう完全麻酔かけたら人にもう自分がもう生きているかどうさえもわからないでしょうしね
寝るとはものすごい違いますね
もう完全に麻酔かけちゃうと
あ 眠くなってきたんだっていう風にグーッと寝るってわけじゃないんですね
経験ある方々いるんだったら説明してあげてください
で 一応まあ麻酔かけたら
この まあ人によりますけど
完全に麻酔かけちゃっても心は回転する人々がいます
その場合は体の中では回転しないんですね
心は自分だけで回転する
だからみんなこの輪廻回転とかなんとかというのはそんなもんなんですね
体に関わって回転しちゃうと痛いとか痒いとか出てくるんだからね
それは薬でも強引に殺しちゃうんですね
まあ体と まあ脳と体の
関係作るところはストップもうロックするんですね
だから脳の機能と体の機能は完全に切り離れちゃうんですね
ほとんどの場合は その時脳は慣れてない場合はね
見ることしか知らないアホだったらね
いろんなことを聞くことしか知らないとかね
そうやって眼耳鼻舌身のそこから
そういうそこら辺だけに回転しているのだったら
もうやることないんだから
まあそこでまあ寝る状態になっちゃうんですけど
そうでない場合もありますけど
その時回転しちゃうんですね
それで自分が体から離れているんだということになっちゃうんですね
体からの情報じゃないんだからね
これ臨死体験なんとかっていって
ものを本なんかに書いてるところありまして
それはそういうことです
で 魂がなんかどこか旅に出たわけでも何でもないんです
大体の場合はもう完全に混ぜられちゃうと
もうもう何も知らん状態になっちゃうんですね
だからこの場合はもうお釈迦様自分の悟りの力で何一つも認識しないことにする
でも不思議なことは これをわざわざ自分でやっていることだから
別に普通に生きてるんですよ
それがもう理解できないことなんです
そのような生き方で生きている時
その戦場に入っている時は人と喋りませんですけど
まあその戦場から起きてから人に会ったりするんでしょうしね
ヴィアランタン そのように生活しているとババンティウポサンカミターロ
尋ね人人々がいるんだと
訪ねてくる人々がいるんだと
ビクビクたちビクニをビクニを比丘尼たちウパーサカ
在家の信者さんたち男性たちウパーシカー
在家の女性の信者さんたち
ラージャの王様たち ラージマハーマッター
王様たちの家来の大臣たち
ティッティア 他の宗教家たち
他の宗教家たち それからティッティエサーヴァカ
他の宗教の弟子たち そうやっていろいろ人が訪ねてくるんだと
タトラアーナンダタタハガタタトラ
その時はアーナンダ如来がタタハガタが
ヴィヴェーカニンネーワチッテーナ
心がヴィヴェーカのニンナヴィヴェーカ状態にもう傾いているのに
その中にも入ってるんですよ
ヴィヴェーカっていうのは
ものすごい楽にいるという普通の訳なんですけど
まあ休息状態というかね
日本訳でヴィヴェーカは何？何言葉になってます？ オンリ
全部オンリですか ネッカも何なんだ
ヴィヴェーナっていうのがオンリと
それから下のチュではネハンって書いてありますけど
ネッカンマっていうことはありますけど
ネッカンマアビラテーナ
ちょっと読んで  そこで如来はオンリに向かい
オンリに傾き オンリに下り
離れ 理欲を喜び 煩悩に基ずく
理欲を喜び  理欲を喜び
煩悩に導く 失礼 煩悩に基づく諸々の法をすべて集結している心によって
必ず送別に関わる話のみを行います
送別というのは別れるとか
それでヴィヴェーカという言葉ですね
専門用語として ヴィヴェーカっていうのは
まああの この まあ逆の通りにオンリということも正しいし
まあヴィヴェーカっていうのは離れるということなんですね
まあ普通はこのまあパーリ語でこの休息という言葉なんですよ
いわゆるさすらいから離れて休息しているんですね
さすらいというのは この見たり聞いたり
楽しかったり 喋ったり
そういうことをやっていることなんですね
で そこ世間ではもう仲良くお茶飲んで喋ることが休息やと思ってますけど
仏教ではそれ休息だと思ってないんですね
すごい心が乱れて混乱している状態で
で まあ仕事をしている時と誰かと喋っている時っていうのは別に同じことなんですね
心が休むわけじゃないんです
ですから 心が回転している間は
もうかなりもうずっと永久的に仕事を真っ最中状態でずっと疲れていくんですね
で まあ唯依化っていうのは
やっぱりこの離れちゃうと見るものからも心離れてもらう
聞く 味わう まあもう考える
感じる すべてのものから心離れ離れておいとく
それで初めて休息ということで
それがまあ  それは涅槃と意味が違うんですか
涅槃ですけど まあだから他の言葉で言えば涅槃ですけど
この場合はやっぱり唯依化っていう言葉を使うんですよ
お釈迦様が悟ったことだから
それはあくまでも涅槃でしょうし
涅槃という経験というかね
その心は涅槃という状態になってしまった
それでその状態に基づいたままで
その状態に傾いたままで
いわゆる俗世間にまた戻って
みんなと仲良くワイワイと
あ お元気ですか？どうですかねとか
なんとかとか そういう風にみんなと合わせるということはしないってことなんです
心が何にしても区別認識しない状態のままに置いておいてということで
そこはすごい絶対的な幸福な状態で
絶対的な休息な状態で
それは誰が来たんだからといってこれを壊したりして
一般で説明で言いますと
一般でいうと思考ストップ状態という解釈とはまた違います
まあそういう単純なことでもないんですけど
ネッカンマ アビラテーナ
アビラタっていうのは何かにこのまあ好きでいるということで
ネッカンマ ナイスカンマ
そこがこの離れることなんですからね
そちらに普通はネッカンマ
隠り使うのネッカンマには隠り使いますけど
欲から離れること そちらにあった言葉は何でしたっけ
欲を喜ぶ 欲から離れたことを喜ぶ
そこでビャンティボウテーナサッダソアーサワッターニーエヒダンメーヒ
このアーサワッターニヤダンマ
煩悩が生まれる現象ですね
あらゆる煩悩が生まれてくる現象から離れてしまってというかな
それでお釈迦様はアンニャダット
これのみという これしかしありませんということでアンニャダという言葉を伝えます
何を喋るかというとウイヨージニーヤパティサンユッタンゲーワカタンカッターホーティ
ただそれだけ喋ってるんだと
いろんな人が訪ねてくる
でもお釈迦様は全然もう誰が来たっても全然相手にしないというかね
自分の心は涅槃に入ったままで
涅槃を喜んで この概念概念思考を何一つも使わない
いわゆる俗世間にはまるっきり合わせないということなんです
あんた王様ですから こちらに座って
あんたは大臣だからこちらとかね
比丘たちはこちら側とかね
そうやって人の各立場とかね
考えたりとかね そうやっていると心が汚れちゃうんですよ
今日は誰が誰が話に来て話に来ているんでしょうかとかね
そんなことはまるっきり関係ないんです
だからこの一般の世界では
この人と喋ろうと思ったら
相手を見た瞬間にもう喋れなくなったりもしますね
もう緊張したりもしますね
それはもう相手の状況は自分の心を横取ってしまったんですよ
それで心がまあ怯えて
まあ緊張したりする まあだから心の安定があれば
まあなかなかまあ 人にうまく上手に喋ることもできますけどね
上手に喋れないということは
やっぱりその相手のことを気になるという
気にすると だから何一つも気にしないという
俗世間のこと だから心は安定なままでいられるんですね
そこで喋ります お釈迦様はいろんなことを話をします
そうすると心が乱れるんでしょう
乱れません で 話のポイントはウイヨージニーヤパティサンユッタン
人間を まあ何と言いますか
ウイヨージ何でしたっけ
で 他の日本語ね 私のところにありますけど
あるんだったら  357ページの
あ 送別 送別に関わる  送別に関わるっていうのは
早く言えばおかえりなさいっていうような意味をあれした言葉を話すっていうんじゃないんでしょうか
なんでウイヨージが送別になったんですかね
こちらには送別と  送別するなんてありませんでしょう
ウイヨージなんてのは応援することなんですよ
尻を叩くことなんです
日本語の場合なら箒を立てるとか
帰ってもらいたい時は箒を立てるとか
お尻を  お尻を叩くということは頑張れということでしょうじゃないの
どうも  ウイヨージ わからないな
漢字は みんなどこかで間違ったらどうもみんな一緒間違えますから
辞書 日本では辞書を引くことほどアホなことがないと思ってるぐらいなんですね
どこかに辞書で言葉を間違ったら
もうずーっともう そばを離れて行きますか？とかそういう意味じゃ
これどういうふうに読みますかね
最後の  刺激かな  だから仏教に上げたんです
どこ  一番最後の  刺激じゃないですよ
次のページに続けて動詞読んでみてください
その次 刺激するっていう
刺激ですか  うん ちょっと離して
うん 排除する 刺激する
放逐 放つ 放逐する だから追い出すとか
そういう意味の排除 うん
排除する  とにかく刺激
追い出す  刺激なんですけど
追い寄るっていうのは悪い意味じゃないんですよ
まあ全部荷物も荷物じゃなくて
お弁当も何から何まで用意してあげて
じゃあ行って頑張れと
その送別なんです  庵に行って頑張りなさいっていう意味を理解して
だから師のところから離れることを分からせるっていう意味ですか
先生  ちょっと分からなかった
刺激するという言葉ですね
それは頑張れとか 今先生がおっしゃった言葉はお尻を叩くとかっておっしゃいましたよね
そう 暗黙のうちに頑張りなさいよっていうことを相手に示唆して分からせて
じゃあ引き上げますっていう心に
じゃあここから先生のそばにいないで
我々は離れて修行に向かいますっていう意味ですかって質問したんです
ややこしくなりますけど
それもうややこしすぎ
だってこの本の通りに先生訳して
日本語で訳してごらんなさいと言うと
こういう形になっちゃうんです
一応意味は言いますから
失礼  お釈迦様はこの何も喋りません
ただ一つだけ喋ります
それは何なのかというと
お釈迦様の言葉を聞いて
人々を 人々の心を刺激してあげるんですね
何に刺激するかっていうと
この俗世間の次元を壊せと
このシュンヤの空のサマーディを作れなさいと
全て捨てなさいと という穏便の話をする
だから穏便の話はもうかなり厳しく言わないとできるもんじゃないんですね
だからお釈迦様の話自体がすごい攻撃的で
刺激的で激しいんです
生ぬるくはないんです
刺激という解釈で  激励ですけど
叱咤っていうのは叱って励ますという意味です
まあまあ叱るということはあまりね
仏教ではまあないんですから
やっぱりまあこれはまあ
智慧の世界だから まあそれはちゃんと説明してあげる
あんた方は苦しんでるんではないかと
瞬間でも安らぎを味わえないんでしょうと
そんなことどこが やるんでしょうかと
そこら辺の俗世間でどこを探したっても
ひとかけらもひとかけらも楽は見つかりませんと
あるのは苦のみだよというふうな話で
ではどうすればいいかという
こういうことで では頑張ってくださいと
そういうことをしない人間が死体と同じだというふうに
そんな話はいっぱいあるんですね
ただ食べて遊んで それはもう死人の塊
集まりだと ずっと死ばっかりだよと
で こちらこそ死を乗り越えている世界だというふうに話して
この慰揚じゃない 応援する人を解脱するために
涅槃に入るために 悟るために
一生懸命この悟りを応援して
悟ることを 修行することをもう応援して
もう話す お話をする ということで
空中の世界に迎えるように
迎えられるように応援する
いわゆる解脱するためにね
修行 修行 真理をね まあこの場合は涅槃
涅槃を体験できるようにということで
人々に応援して話すと
ですから お釈迦様はずっと世の中のことはもう何一つも評価もしないし
受け取ろうともしないし
そういうことは全然気にしないし
人のことでも世間のことでも
ただ涅槃に心をもとづいて
まあ涅槃に傾いた心のままで
あなた方もこうこうすればこちらに来られるのではないかという状態で
話すんですね だから仏教の話
ブッダの話はすべて涅槃という一つの目的を中心に話してるんですね
いわゆるお釈迦様はある境地にいてみんなに話すんだけど
何はともあれみんなそちらに来るような話なんですね
こういうふうに こういうふうに進めばこちらに来られますよ
そっちじゃないんだよと
ここはこういうことだよと
ここをやって こうやって
こうやって こういう風に
この涅槃という土地に来なさいと
それがブッダの教えなんですね
だからブッダの教えは涅槃の道ということになるんです
涅槃に向かった話 涅槃の涅槃に導いた言葉のみブッダの言葉なんです
まあそれからお釈迦様はまた涅槃に導いた話を始めるんです
まあとにかくこのお釈迦様の言葉の中では
この涅槃やいろいろな煩悩のことや
いろいろ説明あるんですけど
で やる気が生まれるように話してるんですね
聞いてやりたいなという気持ちはだいたい生まれるんですね
だから怠け者たちは まあ後でやりますというふうな後回しにするんですけど
もう後ででももうできればいいなという気持ちだけでも生まれるんです
自分にもできればいいなというね
まあそういう人は一応やりませんですけど
まあですからまあ激しく言わなくちゃいけないんですけどね
だからブッダの話を誰が聞いても
どんな違う他宗教の人が読んでも
できれば悪くないよと
という気持ちにはなるんです
だからそちらにはこの激励というかね
刺激というところが入ってるんですね
何に刺激させて 何に激励させているかというと
やっぱり解脱することに
煩悩をなくすことに激励させてるんですね
だからこれからその話をして続けていくんです
タスマティハ
アーナンダ ビック シェーピ アカン ケイヤ アッジャッタン スンニャタン ウパサンパッジャ ビヘレイアンテ
ィ テーナ アーナンダ ビックナ アッジャッタン エーヴァチッタン サンタペータブバン サンニシーダペータブバン
エーコーディカ タブバン サマダハ タブバン
そこでタスマティハ アーナンダですから
アーナンダ ビック シェーピ アカン ケイヤ
もし比丘も希望するならば
欲するならば 上司が先に来るんです
ある比丘が あ 私もそういう状態やりなりたいなとか
もし欲するならばということでやり方説明します
それからそのどういう状態かというと
このアッジャッタン スンニャタン ウパサンパッジャ ビヘレイヨン
私もアッジャッタン 自分の心の中はスンニャタン
シュンヤ状態で 空状態で
にしておきたいなと 私の心の中も空にしたいなと思うならば
じゃあこういう風にしなさいよと
それから激励の話に行くんです
テーナ アナンダ ビックナ
その比丘がこういうふうなことをするべきです
アッジャッタン エーヴァ チッタン サンタ ペータッタン
まず心を外からもう内の中に入れてもらう必要があるんだと
外のあらゆることではなくて
まず中に集中する 自分の中に集中する
で 中にサンタ ペータッタン
集中しなさいということはいくつかの動機語ありますけどね
サン ニッシーダ ペータッタン
自分の思考を心の中に座らせて座らせなさいと
ニッシーダというのは座ること
もう座り込むことなんです
座り込む とにかくもう立ち上がる気持ちもないと
サン ニッシーダティ それ エイコーディ バワン
統一させる サマーダハ ペッタン
定 禅定 統一 同じ統一ですけど
作ると で エイコーディ サマーディっていうのは同じ言葉
サン ニッシーダディっていうのは座るっていうか
サン ニッシーダ ペッタン
まあ座り込むということで
もう立ち上がる気持ちもないぐらいもう座り込んじゃうと
だからどこに心座り込ませてやっちゃうというと
中に で そこはこの瞑想のことはいとも簡単にそれで終わっちゃうんです
そこで瞑想の仕方を説明したんです
すごい短い言葉で 瞑想って何なの？心は中に入れなさいと
中に座り込ませなさい
中へ統一させなさいと
一緒にさせなさいと いろんな現象に心は飛び回ること
歩き回ることやめなさいという
すごい一行で終わっちゃうんですね
詳しく説明するならば
もう浄土論で言ってるあらゆる瞑想法を説明しなくちゃいけないんですよ
では 心を中に内に確立させる
座り込ませる方法は何なのかというと
もう我々は心は乱れて混乱状態でいるんだから
それはもうゆっくりと持ってこないと
難しいんです そうやって40種類の瞑想法いろいろありましたりとかね
それでやり方いろいろ
一つ一つの瞑想法ってやり方またまた違うし
まあそこら辺はもうほとんど準備世界で
こちらは一行で瞑想の世界は終了させちゃうんですね
それで例えば呼吸瞑想ありますね
呼吸瞑想 だいたいお釈迦さんは呼吸瞑想でなさってましたからね
もう一切 一切何も考えないことにする
気にしないことにする
音が入ろうが もう体が寒かろうが
もうまるっきりもう全部まずなかったことにして
もう鼻に空気が触れることだけに集中してみる
それしか認識しませんと
最初は失敗しますけど
でも頑張って頑張って
他の音もう今度は聞かないと
今度は厳密にこの空気が鼻に触れることだけ感じて感じて感じているんだぞと
すっごくきつく決めてやるんです
何回失敗しても このどんどんどんどん気が強くなって
強くなって やるぞやるぞとなってくると
ものすごくこの集中力っていうのは生まれてくるんですね
それでやがてもう他のことを全然気にしない状態になって
それだけ感じていられることになるんですね
その間でいろいろ雑念
妄想などなど出てくるでしょうし
雑念さえも心が飛び出したことなんですよ
外へ世界 雑念も心の中の
実際は心の中の回転なんですけど
機能としては中じゃないんです
機能としてはいろんなことをイメージをしたり
思い浮かんだりするんだから
心はもう飛び出してますよ
例えばこちらで座って瞑想している時は
家のことを思い浮かんだりしますね
それと自分が体で家に行ったこととどちらが違うか
どちらでも同じなんです
こちらに座って家のことを思い出すと
もう心は家なんですね
瞑想をやめて家に帰ったとしますね
同じことだと 一つはただ苦しみが多いだけで
重い物体を運ばなくちゃいけないんだから
だからただ物体を運んでいるかないか
それだけの差ですよ だから妄想思考にものすごい
ものすごい真剣にならないと
で 例えばものすごいもう嫌な気持ちが出てきて
あいつをもう殺してやりたいですよとと思ったら
もうその人殺してるんですよ
結局は ただ何が違うかというと
物体は動かしてない ただそれだけ
でも物体を動かすのも心ですからね
ですから 瞑想中で出てくる様々な妄想について
妄想そのものが その妄想したそのものが
心が外に行っているんだということ
家のことも過去のことも
将来のことを思ったりするとかね
それで機能としてはもう心は歩いているんです
瞑想状態ではありません
で その時はこの瞑想を調整するんですよ
で 中に入れてるもんだよと
どうやって中に入れるんだよと言っちゃうと
この妄想ではなくて 妄想すると自分には貪瞋痴が生まれるんですね
煩悩が 貪瞋痴が内なるものなんですね
だからやっていた雑念ではなくて
欲が生まれた 怒りが生まれたということに認識するんですね
今欲ですと言って また呼吸瞑想だったら呼吸瞑想に行くんです
今怒りですと言って 今怒りだということで
あの考えたことはもうではないんですね
そこで何回も何回も繰り返して繰り返して繰り返して繰り返しやらないとうまくいかないんです
だから心を簡単に 心は中に入れておきなさいと
中に座り込むようにしなさいと言うのは簡単ですけど
それはもうかなり訓練とものすごい勇気と覚悟とすごい強烈に必要になるんですね
で 生半可の気持ちでは全くできません
心はもう歩き回る だからとにかくこの中にエコディバーワン投入させるということは
そういうことなんです
雑念が生まれても雑念の対象ではないんです
うちの機能を心の中の機能がつかまって掴めてみるんです
取ってみるんです だからこの雑念の中に入っちゃうと
外にだから雑念と確認しなさいと言っているんです
雑念と確認すると心の状態を確認しているんです
雑念を確認すると外の状態を確認しているんです
だから雑念とラベリングあっても自分のやり方はもう気をつけないと
雑念と確認するのは 今雑念した現象であるならば
もう外の世界を確認しているんです
だから雑念としている心を確認するんです
雑念 雑念そのものではないんです
あくまでもこの心を確認しているんです
だから雑念 妄想があったら消してないように行くものじゃなくて
あ こういう風に解脱してるんだと
今こういうこういうこと
回転がと この中の働きだけ見ています
で 瞑想の方それだけ それでどんどん雑念ができなくなっちゃうんです
雑念が薄くなって薄くなっていくっていうことは
外の世界に興味がなくなっていくんだっていうことなんです
家のことには興味がなくなっていくっていうことなんです
会社のことにも 五欲の世界には興味がなくなっていくっていうことになっちゃう
それで心は外へ飛び出せなくなっちゃうんですね
で 呼吸瞑想の人だったら
もうただその時は何のことなく
すーっとつなげて呼吸の動きだけ見ているっていうことをまあできるようになるわけです
雑念がなくなっていくっていうことが何なのかというと
貪瞋痴がもう生まれなくなっちゃうんですね
だから瞑想中 昨日食べたことを思い浮かんじゃうと
もう欲が生まれている
明日やること思い浮かんじゃうと
また欲か怒りかどちらか浮かんで汚れているんです
だから雑念が生まれたっていうことは
心が汚れたっていうことなんです
心が汚れているんだったら
もうそれでもまだまだ瞑想は進んでないんですね
それでもう雑念そのものだけ見て
雑念の内容ではなくて
それうまくいくと それから雑念と同時にこの欲を捕まってみる
煩悩を捕まったりしちゃうと
もう中の働きだけ見えるようになってきますし
で それになってくると雑念がどんどん薄くなって出てこなくなる
ほとんど薄くなってくると
呼吸だけ見ることはできるようになってくるんですね
そこまではかなり時間かかりますと思います
年月はかかる可能性あります
それ人によりますけどね
1 日でできる人いますけど
大変な作業なんです  1 行で説明したらそこなんです
何年間の話なんです でもお釈迦様にとってはものすごい単純で
機能としてはね だからまあ
は中に入れておけと それだけで第一禅定なんです
禅定の数では そこで様々な雑念がなくなってしまう
これは完全綺麗さっぱり消えるっていうことでもないんです
雑念がなくなっているんだけど
呼吸はやってるんだから
それは一つの思考パターンでしょうし
で 心はまあ呼吸感じていることだけで十分もう満足している
家なことも昨日のことも
自分の体の健康状態も
まあそんなことはもう気にすることは面白くなくなっちゃって
まあこれで十分満足やと
という状態になってくるんです
それが第一禅定なんです
だから満足だ満足だと思っちゃうと
ものすごい巨大な雑念だからね
だからそこら辺は説明はしにくいんです
なんて楽しいか なんて満足
もうもう妄想ですよ もうそれでもう煩悩生まれてるんです
もうサマディじゃないんです
サマディの説明しにくいところはそういうところなんです
いわゆる満足だ満足だと思うんじゃなくて
満足状態にいるんです
そこで次に行きます カタンチェアーナンダビクアジャッタンゲーワチッタンサンタペーティサンニサーデーティエーコーディカローティサマーダハティー
そこでどうすれば心が中に着いたことになりますかと
と説かせます イダアーナンダビクヴィヴィッチェーワカーメヒヴィヴィッチャクサラレーヒダンメーヒ
そこでヴィヴィッチェーワカーメヒ欲から心を離れてもらう
それはもう私が今説明した雑念からね
あれやりたい これやりたい
これ食べたいとかね 音楽を聞きたい
もっと寝たい 寝たいとかね
休みたいとか そういう欲の世界
で ヴィヴィッチャアクサラダンメ他の諸々の不善のことをね
あれがなければ瞑想をうまくいけるのにとかね
仕事をさ  1週間休めればできる
そういう色んなことが入ったりする
それはアクサラダンメ
不善の考え方なんですね
そういうこのものはもう全部から離れるんですね
いわゆる雑念がなくなっちゃうっていうことなんです
で サヴィタックアンサヴィチャーラン
サヴィタックヴィタックヴィチャーラっていうのは心の仕事ですね
心の仕事っていうのはずっとヴィタックヴィチャーラすることなんですね
いわゆる考えることなんですけど
その心の機能はまだあります
だから この心の考える機能を使って中にこれをやってくださいと
あっちやるんじゃなくて
外のいろんな欲の世界の煩悩の世界の対象の方で考察するんじゃなくて
この中の方で考察してみなさいと
まあ仕事は中にしてもらっちゃうんですね
サヴィタックアンサヴィチャーラン
それでヴィタックヴィチャーラ
まあなんでしたっけ  心の先生の中を対象にして
あの 陣と志の瞑想状態に
陣と志っていうのはいつでもあることで
時計を見る時でも陣と志
志で時計を見るんです
考える時も陣と志でやっちゃう
だから陣と志がないと我々には認識できません
それで そのだったらこれしなさいと仕事を与えてくれるんですね
そこでヴィタックヴィチャーラがありまして
あの ヴィタックヴィチャーラはもう昔何回も説明しましたから
今日はやりたくない で
まあ普通のあの物事 我々見たり聞いたり考えたりする時の心の機能なんです
ヴィタックヴィチャーラって
で 例えばどこかの 部屋に入ったとしますね
今まだ入ったことない部屋に入ります
入った瞬間に目がサッと行っちゃうでしょ
で サッと行っただけでは足りませんね
それからもうちょっと詳しく
あ なるほど こんな感じ
瞬時に起こるんですよ
それでサッと もう一つ
なんとかスナップショットみたいなことを目で撮っちゃうんですね
で ちゃんとピント合わせてスナップショットを撮っちゃうと
目でもうどこに何があるかと
もう大体瞬時に心に入るんですよ
だから一度も入ったことがない部屋のドアを開けて入ったっても
人がきちんと入れますよ
そちらに座る椅子があったらちゃんとそちらに座るし
椅子やと看板書いておく必要もないし
座る人はこの椅子に座りなさいと書いておく必要もないし
で 右側は何かもう机とかなんかあると
そこから行けないっていうことはわかるでしょうし
だったら左に曲がっていって
そちら座ればいいと瞬時にわかるんですよ
だから 初めて部屋に入ったっても
部屋の案内っていうものはいりません
目を回しちゃえばもうわかります
あまりにも複雑な機械やら道具があるとね
これは何のためか 何のためか
それは別な話で 一般的だったらまあわかります
それ説明 知らない 使い方も知らない機械見たら
なんか機械ですよと わからない
それで終わりにちゃいますからね
いじらないんだから いじるべきじゃない
それでもう決まってるんですね
使い方は何もわからない
機械が部屋にあって まず行ってそれをいじるということ
これはありえないことなんです
だから瞬時に我々はヴィタッカヴィチャーラ使う
これはものすごい瞬間の出来事なんです
その機能で我々は知識得たり
いろんな考えたりするのは全てその機能なんです
だから見るときでもヴィタッカヴィチャーラ使う
聞くときでもヴィタッカヴィチャーラ使う
嗅ぐときでもヴィタッカヴィチャーラ使う
味わうときもヴィタッカヴィチャーラ使う
体で感じるときもヴィタッカヴィチャーラ使う
頭で考えるときもすべてヴィタッカヴィチャーラの機能でやってるんです
だから心が認識する場合は必ずもというぐらいヴィタッカヴィチャーラでやってるんです
それでヴィタッカヴィチャーラが外の世界を追っているんだから
そこで外の世界を追うんじゃなくて
ヴィタッカヴィチャーラに頼むんです
内の中を心を見てみなさいと
で それで内を見られるようになったならば
それは第一禅定なんです
先生 今日は最後なので
すぐに御開眼になるので
お疲れのところ申し訳ないんですけど
これは勉強中だからダメだわけにはいかない
こちらに来るように言っておくけど
あ どこへ行くの？では行きます
サッ
ダディティヤジャンダサッダジャヤタスィマセーワサンカーリョー スティティジーラーティトパラボスタサマンタマンターナサンタサッダテータサッダサンターナバ
ーリンサッダサンマンターナバーリンサッダサンガーナバーランカーサッダダンタティーアヴィパサナティーイッサニッサンマンタントサチャーナサッダアーハタマンターマンティーアーユアンノースカンバラン
言えるのは五つまでです
はい えーと それでヴィヴェーカじゃん
その人はこの この こうやって
あの ヴィタク ヴィチャーラって2つの機能をね
人知という機能を で 心の中にしておく
だから中にしておくということはもうわからないんだから
もうわかりやすいのは呼吸とかね
そういう何かにつけてもらっちゃうと
それだけにつけられる
殺念も何も出てこなくなっちゃって
だから殺念出てこなかったっていうことは
欲から離れたっていうことなんですね
欲も怒りももうなくなっちゃう
もういいやと思う まあこちらで忙しいっていうことになるんですね
あれやこれやと考える余裕がないんだと
まあ呼吸を見てるんだと
それがヴィヴェーカと言うんです
穏理と言うんです だから欲の世界からもう離れたんだから
かなり楽を感じるんですよ
例えば 家のことを考えれば考えるほど
離婚の果たし状を出された奥さんのことを考えるほど考えると
心がもうどんどん苦しんじゃうでしょうに
だから我々は余計なあれやこれやと考えるたびに
心がえらく苦しんでるんですよ
だから一度も楽を味わったことがないんだから
もう知らないだけでね
アフガン アフガニスタンのね
まあ人々が爆弾落ちてないだけで
ああ良かったと思うでしょうし
でも平和ってこと知りませんからね
それで今はもう もうすぐ威張ろうとしてるんですね
お前ら出て行けとかね
我々とまたやり合う やっちゃうと
あいつらもう殺さなきゃと
だから結局は平和知らないんですよ
ですから この ほんのちょっとの
あ これで良かったと思うだけで
そんなもんじゃないんですよ
もう我々も平和とかなんだか知ってるんだから
平和って何なのかと 日本に来て
アメリカへ来て ヨーロッパの国々に行ってみたら
平和って何なのかとわかるでしょうに
ですから あの 私たちは一度もこの安らぎというのを味わったことがない
心っていうのは この アフガンにアメリカがずっと集中的に爆弾を落としてる状態にいるんですよ
そこで そこら辺に爆弾を落としたんだけど
こっちが大丈夫だということで喜んじゃうんですね
そんな喜びなんですよ
そこでもうどこかに あの
援助物質なんとかとかね
まあ捨てて捨てるんだからね
配るというよりもね で
そこでもうほんのちょっとの穀物とかなんとかかもしれませんね
それでも百人ぐらい それにもう飛びかかるでしょうし
誰かがグーグー引っ張ったりするとね
もうそんなもうバラバラになって
それちょっと一握り取ったぞと喜んじゃうんですね
確かに飢えている人にとってはそれは最高に楽しいことかもしれません
でも考えてみてください
こっちで我々の子供たち食べているものとね
あの土と拭いて 何か小麦粉やら何か握ってあって
取ったぞと喜んで帰っちゃっても
まあ本人にとっては幸せなんですけど
あんなもんですかね 幸せっていうのは
あんなもんじゃないでしょうに
それで そこから銃 建物に爆弾落とすと
どこかに あの崖に何かに隠れて
まあじーっと待っているんだよね
終わるまでと ああ 終わったと
良かったと あれで良かったと言えるんでしょうかね
だから我々の心の状態
そんなもんです 俗世間で比べてみればわかるんですよ
だから日本に生活している子供たちと考えてみると
どれぐらい贅沢で どんなどれぐらい高価な服を着てね
あまりにも贅沢すぎて体がものすごい弱いというかね
寒さに弱いと暑さに弱いとかも
もうそこまで贅沢しすぎちゃって
で 食べるもの何食べてるかと考えちゃうと
それでアフガンの子供たちって同じ年の同じ子供たちでしょうに
でもその子供たちに聞いたら
どう楽しいか楽しいと必ず言うと思いますよ
何か拾ったらすごい喜びと思いますよ
だからそんな喜びにもう執着しちゃうと成長しないんですよ
ですから この俗世間ではみんな見たり聞いたり
いろんなことをああ楽しい
ああ楽しいやと思って
まあ瞑想しなさいと言っても
くだらないことばっかり考えてるんであって
瞑想はできっこない と
やっぱりそこら辺が楽しいんですね
その楽しみは 私はたとえで言ったアフガンの子供たちの楽しみと同じことになっちゃうしね
それで やっとものすごいもう覚悟を決めて
力強く もうやるんだぞということでやると
もう心はあっちこっちは行くのは興味がなくなっちゃうんですね
まあこっちをここで忙しくてもう間に合ってるんだっていうことになっちゃうんですね
ヴィパッサナーがこの仕事でもう満杯というかね
だから呼吸を見ることでヴィパッサナーがもうもう完璧にもう忙しく
英語で言うんですけど
まあ何て言いますか 使用中
で ヴィパッサナーが呼吸することでも使用中
そうすると あれやこれやと心はいかない
それは仏教でオンリーの境地なんです
それでものすごい喜び
楽しみというか 気楽と楽が生まれてくるんです
だからヴィヴェカジャンっていうのはオンリーの状態
オンリーから生まれてくる
ピーティスカン ピーティっていうのは喜び
スカっていうのは楽ですね
喜びで楽が生まれてくるんですね
それにパタマージャナ第一禅定というんです
だから第一禅定を作ったということは
心の中に入れたということです
そこでできたならば もうこのヴィパッサナーで認識しているんだから
それがなければ動くいかないんですよ
で 中に心が統一したところで
すごい喜びを感じられる
そこが上手になってくると
もうヴィパッサナーの用が済んじゃうんですよ
ある意味ではヴィパッサナー機能というのは危険なところもありますね
もう何でももう捕まっちゃいますからね
もう眼耳鼻舌身意に入る情報っていうのはもう何でも受け取れる機能ですから
だから何でも受け取る機能を持っていること自体はちょっと危険です
受け取っちゃいますからね
何でも 例えばもうまあ
自分がもうすごい危険なところにいて
こちらお城みたいなものがあるとします
そこでお城の周りは泥とかいろいろあって
もうなかなかもうもう自分がそちらにいて危険ですね
そこでこのロープウェイでありますね
あれは何？はしごと言うんですか？この
縄ばしごありますね そこでこれはかかってもらって
自分が苦労して苦労して上に登る
登ってないんだけど それからもういろいろ泥棒やらもうワニでも登ってくる可能性あります
だから縄ばしご 縄ばしごは自分にとっては役に立ったんだけど
これは誰にでも入りますからね
それでみんな安全がなくなっちゃうんですね
だけど そこは上から捨てちゃう
いらんと それからいくらワニが待っていたって
もう登れなくなっちゃうんですね
自分を殺そうとして 誰かもう終わり
もう入らなくなっちゃうんですね
あの昔の映画なんかで
この昔のお城の世界なんか描いてる場合は
この何といいますか ほとりというんですか
あの大きな  お城がありまして
その周りに堀を作ってあるんです
それで敵が来たり 通行するときは橋をかけるんですが
敵が攻めてくる時はその橋を上げてしまう
だから橋をかけたままだったら誰でも入っちゃうんですね
でも自分が安全なお城に入るための橋が必要なんですよ
それを使って入るんです
入ったらサッサッサッとそれを橋を上げちゃうと
そういうことで 我々の心には
には今はヴィタッカヴィチャーラが必要なんですよ
情報を収集するために
縄ばしごってことになるんですね
それは  それでこれで一応統一してもらう心を余計なことをしないで
一つだけ見ることになってもらう
それになってもらったらすごく楽を感じる
あ これで大変楽しくて楽じゃないかと
やっと休息を感じる それで休息は感じていないんだけど
この縄ばしごというか
この橋があると ちょっとどこかからまた情報が入る可能性あるんですね
で さらに集中すると このヴィタッカヴィチャーラが消えちゃうんですね
ヴィタッカヴィチャーラが消えたら
ものすごく安定した禅定状態が生まれてきます
ヴィタッカヴィチャーラ消えると
もう言葉はほとんど消えちゃう
言葉消えちゃう 頭の中で言葉機能はストップします
で 言葉機能しちゃうと危険ですよ
言葉と一緒に感情がついてますからね
第1禅定では言葉の機能はあるんです
第2禅定ではもう言葉はないし
言葉は全部沈静めちゃう
でもずっと統一しています
アッジャッタンサンパサーダナン チェータソエーコーディバワン アヴィタッカンアヴィチャーラン
アッジャッタンサンパサーダナン
中で大変もう柔らかになるというか
喜びを感じる状態になって
満足感じる状態になりまして
チェータソエーコーディバワン 心は統一していて
アヴィタッカンアヴィチャーラン ヴィタッカヴィチャーラがないし
サマーディジャン このお釈迦様サマーディという言葉を使うのは 第2禅定なんです
仏教では 第1もサマーディなんですけど
お釈迦様の言葉ではもうサマーディという言葉は 2に使ってるんですよ
ヴィタッカヴィチャーラだから
これちょっと危なっこいというかね
いつ落ちるかわからないという状態だから
ヴィタッカヴィチャーラ消えたら
もう言葉のレベル消えちゃうと
もうサマーディということですね
そこでピーティスが大変喜びを感じるようになるんだと
そのように 第3禅定がありますし
第4禅定もあります この禅定が 4までいくと
もう一応どんどんこのあらゆるこの内の心の状態でも
この粗っぽい状態はもっともっとなくなっちゃって
まあまあピーティが消えちゃう
ピーティっていうのは喜びですね
まあちょっと派手すぎだと
ただ楽だけ残っちゃう
第3禅定で  第4禅定 楽だ楽だ
その気持ちもなくなっちゃって
別に楽とも何も思わない状態になって
ウペッカー状態になってくる
まあそういう感覚の差だけなんです
第3と4は  第1は禅定の入り口
禅定なんですけど まあまだまだ身についてないというかね
まあちょっと危ない状態で
これでヴィタッカヴィチャーラを飛ばしちゃえば
もう禅定なんですね それで喜と楽があるんですね
喜がちょっと荒っぽいというか
ちょっと激しすぎだから
それもなくなって楽になって
それから喜楽両方なくなってシャー
ウペッカー状態になってくる
だからそれだけの差なんで
その分分サマーディ状態がどんどん強化していくんです
そうアッジャッタン 次にそれ第四禅定までできたとします
アッジャッタン スンニャタン マニシカロティ
もう心の中で概念ないんだからね
言葉もないんだからね
心は落ち着いて もうほとんどのものが消えちゃったんだという
この心の中のスンニャタ
空であることは観察始めるんですね
観察をしようとしてもなかなかできなくなるんです
第4禅定になったところで
シャーのウペッカーのもう喜も楽もない状態で
もうクールな状態で心いて言葉も機能しないし
外の世界ってまるっきりもう知らないし
心は今自分が観察してる一つの対象にだけ据えているし
そこでスンニャにしてみようかなという気持ちでスンニャを観察しようとしますが
もうできなくなっちゃうんです
難しいんですよ だから心があるものを見るようになっていたのであって
何がないかということはなかなか見られないんですね
それはもう決まってます
そう簡単にスンニャはつかめません
大変この空を認識するということはものすごい一番難しいことで
だからこの前の経典で空を認識する方法を説明しましたので
そこら辺はこの読み 思い出してみればいいんじゃないかなと
で リピート放送はできません
で なかなか大変ですよ
この建物を見てね 建物が見るのは簡単ですよ
建物はあっても 建物を占領している空間を見ようではないか
もう知識では 論理ではもうまあなんだ
でも認識としてはどうですか？認識できますかね
ということで 建物はこれぐらい空間を占領しているんだぞとかね
もう電卓で計算してあげたりとか
これぐらい立方メートルやとかね
それ一つの空間ではないんですよ
全部もう空間の認識ではありません
確かにこの建物はある空間を占領しています
そこで我々の目には建物が入っちゃうんですね
それで心を育てた人は建物を認識しないで
建物を占領している空間を認識しようとする
それがシューニャタの見方なんです
それは第4禅定に行った人が
ではシューニャタを認識してやるんだよと言っても
自分の心の今の状態しか認識できなくなっちゃうんですよ
だからうまくいかないと
難しいと だからうまくいかないということは
もうこれでお釈迦様そのまんま言ってるんだから
いかにも難しいかと  第1から4まで禅定というのは軽々く
なんかもうどんな馬鹿にもできそうという感じで説明して
シューニャタになってくると
そこはもう第4禅定まで行った比丘もなかなか大変だと
タッサ エヴァン サンタン エタン アナンダ ビク エヴァン パジャナーティ
この状態になったら この比丘がこういうふうなことを知ると
アッジャッタン シュンヤタン コウメイ マネシカロ ト アッジャッタン シュンヤタラ チッタンナ パッカンダティ ナッパシーダティ
ナサンティッペティ ナヴィムッチャティティ
私は内の内 いわば心の中のシューニャを見ようとしたんだけど
まあダメでしたと 統一できなかったと
イティハ タッタ サンパジャーノホーティ
で だったらまあまた一からやり直しましょうということにお釈迦様はまたやり方
もうやりやすい方法を説明しますね
その時はこういう風に観察してみようではないかと
内に視視した後にそれを承知して
その後は彼は外に空性を視視します
で イティハ タッタ サンパジャーノホーティ
彼はそれについて承知します
コンマ ターワナ が承知しない
サンパジャーナ まあこのようにやりましょうと
その人が空性に統一していない場合は
やり方はこのやり方ですよと
お釈迦様はやり方を説明しているんです
ソ バヒッダ シュンヤタン マネシカロティ
外の世界の空性を観察します
ソ アッジャッタ バヒッダ シュンヤタン マネシカロティ
ソ アーナニャン マネシカロティ
タッサ アーナニャナン マネシカロト アーナニャジ チッタンナ パッカンダティ ナッパシーダティ ナサンティッペティ ナヴィムッチャティ
これはね 説明してても意味があるんでしょうかね
外の世界の空性を観察する
外の世界の空性っていうのは
まあいくら観察できそうではないかなと
五欲をもう五欲から離れてるんじゃないかと
五欲を離れた状態ですね
このその空であることをもう全部消えちゃったんだと
もうないということでね
外の世界を損させていたんですね
今まではね だからこの禅定に入っちゃうと
その世界消えちゃうね
現に身心の世界は消えてしまっているんです
だからその世界も消えちゃったと
その空性はだいたいわかりやすいんですね
だいたいでもなく かなりわかりやすい
それ観察する それで外の世界は空になったところで
その分心も空になったんではないかと
そこで比較的にわかってきます
そこで両方まとめて 外も内も空である
空性であることを観察します
ナマとルーパの両方  ん？ 内と外ってナマとルーパに当てはめて
これはサマーディの世界ですからね
だから私の話に乗っていればわかると思いますけどね
もう乗ってないと全くもう難しいんですよ
サスレン思考を離れてこの言葉のみを入れないと
とにかくこの第四禅定の話には乗ってこないともう全くもうできません
これはもうどうしようもならない
どうにもならないんだ
サマーディの世界だからね
だからサマーディなくても
この自分たちの概念を捨てて
この私が言うことにほんのわずかの時間だけでもいいんですけど
ちょっと信頼してもらえばね
理解できると思いますけど
理解ぐらいでも 自分にも説明する気力も全部消えちゃったんです
では 皆様の学識のレベルに戻ってしゃべりしゃべります
で その方が仏教では色界とかね
無色界とかね 禅定のレベル 2つあるんですね
時々私にも教えてあげようとしてるでしょ？この第一禅定
第二禅定とかね まあそういう 第4禅定まで色
色界の禅定に 色界の禅定からは無色界の禅定に飛びなく
飛ぶなくちゃいけないんですよ
これがもうなかなか大変で
なかなかそこは心は無色界には向かないんですよ
それで お釈迦様はこの色界に色界の世界にぐるぐるぐるぐる回っている心は
無色界に飛び出させる方法を教えているんですよ
だからはっきりとこのマハースーニョータ経典は読んだ方読まない方がいいので
これはもう修行者に教える厳密なこの修行方法なんです
一般の方々には全く関係ないというかね
もう分かったもんじゃないと思いますけどね
でも驚くことは これを極めて簡単な言葉でお釈迦様もおっしゃっているんだからね
で あの呼吸瞑想説明すると
第4禅定に入っても いわゆる呼吸を観察しているんです
思考は何もない もう言葉もない
でも呼吸は観察しているんです
それで心が統一します
それでヴィターッカヴィチャーラが消えちゃう
ヴィターッカヴィチャーラというのは何か知りたがるという興味みたいなものでね
あの知るというあの知識の式書かないとね
この認識したがるという知りたがるなんです
で この知りたがる能力あるとサマーディが危険です
カラスの鳴き声も聞きたがるんだったら
カラスの鳴き声を聞いてしまっちゃうでしょう？サマーディが壊れちゃう
ですから 第1禅定に入った人がこの認識したがる
そのヴィターッカヴィチャーラをもうなくすんですね
なくしたらもう知りたがる機能を持っていないんだから
カラスが鳴こうが雷が落ちろうが
もうサマーディでいられるんです
知りたくはないんだからね
認識したくないんだからね
それですごい喜びがありまして
もう喜というね すごい喜びがあって
これは派手すぎ それで喜び薄く
薄くなって あの苦楽っていうこと
薄くなって 別にもう楽なことではないんですよって
そこまで心が安定していくんですね
だから安定はするんだけど
ものすごい強力にこの急速感は感じるんです
そこから空に空性に行こうではないかとチャレンジする
でも空性っていうのは論理上無理なことで
で 頑張るんだけど 自分には自分の心しか見えないんですよ
自分の心の状態は感じられます
じゃあ空性にしようかなと言ったっても
自分の禅定に戻っちゃうんです
ではまたもう一回頑張って
もう空性にしてみようかなと言って
まだ自分得た禅定で落ちちゃうんですね
どう頑張ってもあの前の状態に落ちるんですよ
落ちるということは サマーディから落ちるんじゃないんです
自分がサマーディ経験あるんです
それで瞑想を始めたら
その状態に行って じゃあ頑張ろう頑張るしたっても
その状態にまたまたまたまたまたまた戻って戻って
どうにもならなくなっちゃう
その場合は その人はじゃあちょっとこの同じワンパターンのやり方ではなくて
もうちょっと瞑想のやり方変えようではないかと
それで初めて呼吸瞑想をやめるんですね
呼吸瞑想中 説明すると
やめて じゃあ今私はどうなったんでしょうかと
瞑想する前には瞑想する前には世の中のことは全部考えていたんです
今自分の心にはそれがないんだと
それはすごくわかりやすい
私にとっては外の世界はもう消えちゃったと
例で例えば目を開けていると巨大な世界見えるでしょうね
目を閉じた瞬間で消えるでしょうね
だから本当に楽になっちゃうんです
例えわずかでも楽やとか目を閉じたら
それで何となく消えちゃったのが楽なんですね
そうやってもうそれはもう消えてしまった外の世界でわかる
なんとか納得いける それで同時に認識してた心もかなり激しく勢いで変えていたんだけど
心のも仕事もかなり消えたんではないか
その内の空性消えたこと
外の空性を観察してみます
次にアーネーニャ作ろうというステップになる
アーネンジャっていうのはサマーディのことなんですけど
無色界のサマーディにはアーネンジャという言葉を使うんです
だからサマーディに使う言葉は 2つあります
あまり普通の世界の人って知らないんです
その言葉を知ってるんだったら偉そうなこと言うでしょうと思いますけど
誰もサマーディという言葉しか知らないんです
サマーディってそこらのこの第4戦場まで
それからはアーネンジャなんです
アーネンジャの意味っていうのは
このしっかりしているんだという
いわゆる不動という意味なんですね
日本訳ではなんですけど
不動 不動ですね  不動自在心
それではこのないものについて心を不動に状態に持っていけるかと
これはちょっと論理的には無理ですよ
子供なんか落ち着いてもらいたければ
ゲームなんかさせちゃえばもう落ち着いてくれるでしょうね
それに集中 だからあるものだったら簡単ですよ
ゲーム機を奪って落ち着いてもらおうと思ってできるかと
例えばゲームやってるとギャーギャーギャーギャーと言ったり喋ったりうるさい
落ち着いてもらおう じゃあゲーム機をもう没収と
したところで 子供はまあやることもないんだからじーっと見ましょうとなるんでしょうかね
もうこれ無理ですね だから
まあでは子供の例で説明します
子供が部屋に入ってあっち走る
こっち走る あれは蹴るは
これ蹴るは 上飛んじゃうわ
もう結構もう触ろうとするわとかね
もう逆立ちするは もう大変
もう大騒ぎ それで まあこの子供たちはもうちょっと力ありすぎて大騒ぎだと
じゃあ落ち着いてもらおうと思って
君こっち来て 面白いゲームありますよと
じゃあこのゲームをやりますからね
これやってみると言っちゃうと
これ子供はもう飛ぶことも逆立ちすることも全部やめちゃって
駆け もう駆け子 駆け子なんて言いますか
走り回ることあるでしょ
いろいろ鬼ごっこやらね
で そんなこと全部やめて
どこかにもう座り込んじゃって
ゲームやっていると それでやっていると
子供またもういろいろあれほど激しくはないんだけど
いろんなことをやっちゃうんですね
キャーキャーとか もうもうなんだよなんだよとかね
出てこいよ 出てこいよとかね
ずるいぞとかね 負けそうになったり
そうやって まあこいつはうるさいと
それ それで子供からゲーム機も奪うと
もしゲーム機 奪われたところで
子供はそのうるさいよ
するいそうとかなんとかとかね
もうもう行け行けとかなんとか言ってゲームやったこともやめて
じっといてもらえばということ
まずダメでしょうね 結局は我々の心にもその同じ状態の進み方なんです
だからもうダメっていうのはもうダメになっちゃうんですよ
だからこの 第4戦場まではゲーム機でやってるんです
そこで無意識下になっちゃうところでゲーム機も取ってもらうんです
だからかなり戦場としてはすごい難しいところなんです
そこで子供の例でも考えた
でも子供にとっては走ったり
駆けっこをやったり いろんなことをしたりすると疲れるでしょうし
それだったらもうゲームやっちゃうと指 2本だけの動きだから
そんなに疲れることはない
体力的には でもゲームの中にいろいろ喜びやったりしますから
それ分でも疲れるんですね
それでこれ疲れるんだぞとわかったところで
疲れるんだとわかってもらわなきゃダメなんですね
あ これも前は面白かったんだけど
もう疲れたんだと だったらゲーム機はなしということにしましょうと
それでゲーム機を置いておいて
何のことなくじっと座っていただければ
その方が子供にとって前よりも楽なんですよ
ゲーム機から出てきた苦しみがもう消えたんだから
そこで私たちにいたっても
ゲーム機で遊ぶことは 第4戦場まで
それで疲れを感じて もっと楽になりたいなと思ってもらわないとまず無理
それでゲーム機を置いておく
置いといたってうまくいかないんですよ
やっぱりあれ また取りましょうと
また取っちゃうんです
で またこれ疲れるんだから
じゃあ何もないことにします
やっぱりまたということで
いつでも 第4戦場に陥るんですね
それで観察しますよ 子供の例にまた戻ります
子供はもうゲーム機を奪われたと
だったらもう部屋中走り回るかな
あれ ちょっと待ってくれ
部屋中走り回って もうあっちあっちぶつけて
こっちぶつけて いろいろ敷かれたりとか
もう嫌でしたと 結構疲れたんだと
走り回ることをやめたところで楽ではなかったということに集中しますね
だから走り回って楽しかった
楽しかったではなくて
それやめて楽しかった
楽になったんではないかというふうに思っちゃうんですね
ですから もう二度とこの走り回ることにはもう戻らないということにして
それやめたことで落ち着くんじゃないかなと思うと
それは外の苦を感じることと
それは例えられますね
ですから もう今何も認識しないんだと
何も妄想しないんだと
自分がああ楽だと この妄想しないことを観察してみる
それで走り回らないと
いろんな妄想をしないっていると
心は落ち着いてますね
そこで心にあった激しい波も消えているのではないか
そこ消えている状態を観察するということで仕事をしていくんですね
それはいいんだけど 観察だけだったらアーナンジャ
サマーディじゃないんですね
仕事最中だからね で サマーディもそれそれで空に基づいたサマーディ
対象で認識するのは論理なんです
対象ないことに集中するということは
もう論理飛ばしちゃうんですよ
論理も科学も飛びちゃうんですね
第4戦場までは科学的なんです
だったら反応は何かぶつけたら反応するんですね
だから心はいろんな情報に心にぶつけると反応する
それは認識というんです
そこで一つの情報に認識のみ認識するようにする
そうすると心はかなり楽になる
それは戦場の世界で そこで何も情報を触れないことに認識してみなさいと言っちゃうと
これ論理的に無理なんです
だからもう科学的にもこれはありえないんだよ
ということになるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりそれもできます
だからこのすごい回転
心の次元の回転なんだから
色界と無色界と言うんだからね
思考パターンはものすごい違う
だからないということを認識するというのはね
それも順番で行くんです
少々もう少々ないことにして
もっとないことにして
もう完全にないことにするんです
だから無色界にしたっても段階があるんですね
本当の空性はその段階目終わってから出てくるんです
四禅定やって その後段階行って
それ終わった後に現れる
それがブッダの空性なんです
そこでこのアーナンジャを作りたい場合は
不動というサマーディなんですよ
アーナンジャを作りたい場合は
もう空は空は観察できるようにはなるんですけど
アーナンジャにはならない
統一はしない それでお釈迦様はちょっとした工夫を教えちゃうんです
だったら あなたの番目のサマーディに戻りなさいと
サマーディに戻って 統一性をこんなもんやとちょっとわかってもらう
それからまた空性を観察する
それからまたサマーディに戻ってみる
それはまた空を空性を観察してみる
それで 2つ合わせてもらっちゃうんですね
サマーディ統一状態です
第4禅定に合わせるんじゃないんです
第4禅定にあるこの統一状態をとって空性に繋げちゃうんです
そこで空性に統一する
まあこれはもう try エラーでっていうね
もうまあやる人にとってはそんなにということでもないんですけどね
だからもう喋る世界じゃない
とにかくこんなものは
大この無色界の話はもうこの仏典以外はどこにもないんだから
言葉だけ大乗経典なんかに出てくるのは
ただ 言葉は当然ありますからね
本当にこれはどれほど難しくて
どんなもんかと思う 全くもないんです
インド教的な瞑想やらね
念仏のサマーディとかはまあ延々と説明してやりますけどね
これはもうすごい技術ですよ
心の だからもうすごく管理して
丁寧に心を訓練して訓練して
その技術を身につけて持っていくんですね
そこで 第4禅定までゲームで遊ぶ
たとえに戻ります ゲームに戻るんじゃなくて
ゲームやってる時は自分がずっと集中していたのではないかという
この集中した状態だけ学んでもらう
それを空性に繋げてみると
そんな簡単にはアーナンジャは出てこない
だから空性を見る事さえ難しいし
でも頑張ればすぐ見られちゃうし
で それからもうでもアーナンジャが出てくる
そうすると 第4禅定に戻ってみて
それを からちょっと学んでもらって
こんな感じやっていうことで
ではっていう風にやっちゃうんです
このように繰り返して繰り返してやる
繰り返す 外の空想を観察して
第4戦場の統一状態のみを観察して合わせてみよう
合わせてみよう もう何回もやらないと合わせることできないね
まだちょっとなんか合わせたように気がするんだけど
またダメになっちゃうとかね
また外の空想をやって
またサマーディの統一性を見て
またまたそれで合わせること出てくる
それから内の空想を見て
心の中の状態を見て それを前に先にやった 第4戦場の統一状態に
もう行ったり来たり 行ったり来たり
行ったり来たり 合わせて合わせたりする
それから外と内の空想をまとめてみて
戦場に合わせてみようかな
合わせてみようかなということで
なんとかそれできるようになったら
それはもう安寧になるんですね
そういう順番でゆっくりとやるんです
で 安寧ジェ アーナ アーネンジェ
チッタン アーナンジェ
アーナンジェ アーネンジェっていうのは普通私は使って
口癖かな アーネ アーネンジェ
アーナンジェ 両方使ってますね
だから言葉には不動なんですけど
本当はこれ専門用語で
これはこの無色界のサマーディを表すためにサマーディという言葉を使わないということ
で 不浄ということは だから
だからお釈迦様が不動という言葉を使ったのは
これはすごい論理的で
ものすごい論理なんです
言葉の選び方は 何に集中するかというと
空に集中するんだから
だから不動でしょう 動かないでしょう
サマーディの場合は何かに集中する
呼吸やらいろいろ瞑想体操ありますからね
念仏やら呪文やらもう何かに現象に集中する
その現象に依存しているんですね
サマーディは だから波があるんですよ
だから空に集中すると
もう何もない状態だから
こちらにも何も反応できないんですね
そこが不動という状態なんですね
なんとか例えでいきましょう
まあ例えば手を開いてもらって
いろいろビー玉を手に落とすと
私は手を見ないでいる
じゃあビー玉いろいろ落としてください
それで人が手にいろいろビー玉を落とすと
私はその腕感じるんですね
それはいたずらされちゃって
ビー玉ではなくて ものすごい 1kgぐらい重いものをボソンと落とすかもしれませんしね
で とにかくそれでももうその場合はものすごく痛いとかね
ビー玉だったらそれぐらいとか
ピンポン玉を落としたらこれぐらいとか
そうやって感じていますね
その場合は手の感覚はどうでしょう
動いてますね それでまあ空を落としてもらう
まあピンポン玉の代わりにシャボン玉も重いんだからね
まあ私にそれあまり意味がない
私にはシャボン玉重く感じますけどね
手に落としちゃうと すごくっていうのはちょっとおかしいんですけど
やっぱり重さは感じるんです
それでシャボン玉 シャボン玉を落としてもらうと
まずは温度の差がありますから
もう同じ温度にしましょう
手にもいっぱいシャボンの水を塗ってもらって
シャボン玉を落とすと
1個落としてもらう  1個落としてもらうと
全然わからない それであなたの手の感覚はどうですかと
ずっと同じですよと その状態だったら変わるわけじゃないんだと
ということで ああ 不動という
だからまあそういう風にでも理解しないと
例えも偉い もう大変苦しいんです
例えにしたっても まあとにかくこの音楽の場合は音を聴いて楽しい
だけど心が反応するんですよ
そこでこの音楽の場合は
音が流れて流れて ある突然ピリオドが入っちゃうでしょ
突然パッとストップしちゃうとかね
全部楽器はちょっとストップする
そのピリオドも音楽の一部なんですよ
だから その時の反応は何なのかと
音楽は聴いてる真っ最中なんですよ
その場合は何のことなくピリオドも聞く
あの何も音ない  無音状態を
も聞くでしょうね  聞いてます
だから一番気楽っていうのはこの状態なんですけど
でも無音状態だけだったら誰も音楽と思わない
だからそれはもう俗世間だからね
もし人が心は育った人がいるならば
その人よく考えて まあヴァイオリンも面白いし
打楽器も面白いし でもどんどん聞いてるとちょっとね
もう疲れるんだよと 音楽は気楽になるために聴くものではないかと
で 聞いたところで この演奏の真っ最中で突然無音状態になった瞬間ですごい気持ちが
まあオーケストラとかいろいろの場合
まあ日本の音楽の場合はその
あの無音状態をよく使ってますね
西洋ではもう まあ毛が立ちますからね
あんまりにももううるさいというかね
で あまり無音状態っていうのはないんですけども
いやらしい すごい聞こえる音作るでしょうに
聞いてるか聞いてない
聞き聞こえないんですよ
あれ えらく腹が立つんですよ
私の場合はね まあそこは向こう狙ってるんだけど
こっちは喜べないんで
狙ってることわかってますけどね
向こうはいつでも何か物体的にプレゼンテーションする世界でしょ
西洋的な それでいろんな激しいことを
季節の変わり目やら それからじっと静かになってて
一本だけのバイオリンをゆっくり弾くとかね
こっちはうるさいこの野郎と言いたいところになるんですよ
腹が立ってきます なぜなら
だからそちらは音があるんだい
あるんだよと 聞こえないぐらい音があるんだよという気持ち作っちゃうでしょうね
この聞こえない音って何なのか
そんなことこう気持ちが生まれるんだからね
だから私個人の場合はすごく腹が立ってくる
でも日本の場合はなんか音はいきなりそこでカッと止まって
自然に全くこのサイレントにしてくれるんです
まあサイレントだからね
同じ流れで音が消えた瞬間も喜べるんです
だから別にもうその気持ちはいいんです
いろいろいろいろ激しい音があってからきちんと止まって
きちんと止まるんだから
はっきりと だから無音状態でしょ
だから私 音楽っていうのは個人の好みで聴くもんだから
わがまま言えますから
言ってますと言いますけど
その場合は気楽で聴いていられます
あの場合は じゃあもうまあ
これはものすごい低い音だから聞いてやろうと思っちゃうと
何か損した気持ちになるんです
それから次に始まるものすごい恐ろしい打打だけ始まりますから
じゃあそこから聴くそうと言ったら
なんか繋ぎがなくなっちゃって損したこと
だから一本のバイオリンだけゆっくり弾くんだったら
それも聴かなくちゃいけないんですよ
あれ えらい精神的な苦しみというか
いじめというか もうもう気に入らんことですよ
だからストップっていうのはもう終わり
聞くなよということだからね
聞かなくちゃいいんだから
それ自動的に聴覚もあの激しい音からきちんと受け取らないという瞬間になってくれるんですね
波に乗っていればね 音楽の世界では
そこで そこはもう世俗的な世界で
瞑想の例えには一つもなりません
そこで瞑想の例えというのはえらい難しい
特別もうありえない世界のことだから
ある人が では同じ音楽ピースの中でも
自分が一番穏やかになったのはどんな瞬間かというと
無音の瞬間ではないかと
では無音の瞬間の続きはいかがでしょうか？ともし 30 分ぐらいでもね
たった 5 分だけでも まるっきり無音の状態を受け取って
あ 気持ちいいと思えるならば
なんとなく空想の世界に似ているんです
聴覚はもう反応しない状態で
でも聴覚を媒介して喜びを感じているというややこしい状態
で 聴いてる 聴いて楽しむ世界だから
聴いて楽しむ世界だったら聴覚でしょうね
何を聴いているかというと
無音を聴いている ということは
物理的には聴覚は振動していないんです
空想っていうのはそういうふうな世界なんです
そのたとえで俺と同じってわけじゃないんです
そのたとえで言い換えると
認識は物があって認識する
それでないことにも認識してみようと
我々は今も楽を感じる場合
楽を感じるのはない時なんです
本当に終わったぞということで楽を感じているんですよ
終わってないとすごいストレス感じてるんです
だから人間 人生は楽しい
楽しいと言うんだけど
厳密に微細に分析してみると
いつ楽を感じたかというと
何か終わった時 楽を感じるんですよ
生まれた時ではなくて
消えた時 楽を感じるんです
だから本当にこの世俗世界でもみんな喜びは感じてますよ
みんなわかってないだけで
これがあるんだから楽しいというふうに思ってるんだけど
これはもう量子素粒子のレベルで分析してみてほしいんです
分析してみると 消えた瞬間で楽を感じるんです
それまたたとえは簡単にもうこれ荷物ちょっと持っていてくださいと
荷物を任される それでずっと持ってるんですよ
これ苦しいんですよ 痛い
苦しい ちょっと待ってください
もう置いとくなよと 置いておけません
もうこれは棚をちゃんと片付くまで下に置くものじゃ大事なものやと
したら この人の大事な床に置くわけにもいきませんし
持っていて持ってても苦しい
それではい わかりました
はい わかりました はい
どうぞ置かせてくださいと
その人は渡すんですよ
あの渡った瞬間で重さが消えちゃう
あの瞬間が楽しいんです
その瞬間次からまた有の世界が手があるんじゃないか
それからまた普通あの楽しみもずらっと消えてしまって
普通に戻るんですね だからいつでも楽しみっていうのは終わった瞬間なんですよ
マラソン走ってる時は苦しいんですよ
でもゴールが見え始めると
どんどん楽しみが追われてくるんですよ
そこであの何とかあれ
リボンありますね あのリボンに胸触れて
あの白い線に飛んだ瞬間で楽しいんです
終わったと それからまた苦しいんですけど
あの瞬間の楽しみなんでみんな狙っているの
だから何回でもやりたいと言うんですよ
だから実際にも我々味わっている楽しみっていうのは
無から生まれるんです
有からは苦なんです だから何でも同じこと
お腹が空いてるとご飯食べて楽しいでしょ
みんなバカだからご飯食べること楽しいと思ってる
そうじゃないんです あの空腹感が消えること楽しいんですよ
それで喜び感じるんですよ
それだったら空腹感もないのにも食べてみてください
えらい苦しいんです 気持ち悪いんです
だから精神的な問題ある人だけパクパクパクパク食べちゃうんです
苦しいんですよ だからどんな時でも消える瞬間で楽しい
だからもう人間悟らないのはそういうわけ
だって世の中見たっても
いつでも物事生まれては消えていくでしょうに
だから苦しみが生まれちゃうんだけど
消えちゃいます 消える時は喜んじゃいますから
ああ 消えてよかったと
だから一向に解脱しようとはしないということになっちゃうんです
だからどんなものでも現れては消えますからね
そこで まあいいんじゃないかと
みんな思ってしまっちゃうんです
何言うんですかとか 生きることもそれでなかなか楽しいよ
でもバカじゃないかと
あんた方はこの有に楽をつけているんだよと
だから追っていくんだと
あれ欲しい これ欲しいと
じゃなくて 楽を無でもらいますよと
だから無になってみなよと
そうすると楽のみや この無になってもらうということ
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想でも
あの進んでレベルでは
あの生滅ということを観察させちゃうんですね
生と滅 生と滅 生と滅 それで何のことなくわかるんですよ
生と一緒に苦が生まれるんだと
滅の時が良かったと 消えて良かったと
それでどんどん心が滅の方に行こうとする
行こうとするんだけど
これと同じくもうもう何何億回も失敗する
分かってはいるんですよ
有は苦で無は楽やと 無に行きたいな
でもダメでまた有に戻れちゃうんです
そこでまたやり返し 何回なんかもやってやって
やってやって この生滅を生滅見て見て見て見て
で 見られる時なんですね
強引に見てもあまりね
意味がないんだけど それでやっぱり激しく心がこのもう激しい感情状態みたいなもんなんですけども
なんでできんかと できんということに気づくんですよ
解脱は得られんと というて
ということを私もずっと火の中にいなくちゃいかんではないかという
ものすごい恐怖感が出てくるんです
そのものすごい恐怖感が出てきた瞬間にもう悟りの心があるんです
これは すごい激しい まあそれで
とにかくヴィパッサナーにも使ってるのと同じ論理で
こちらはサマージの世界でも同じことはものすごい厳密に説明していて
本当の楽っていうのは有ではなくて無だよということで
世の中 自分の生き方もこれから観察してみてください
毎日楽しいことはいっぱいあるでしょうに
何が楽しいか 本当は無が楽しいんですよ
ではこういうこと 誰かすごい執達
もう友人がお土産いっぱい持って訪ねると
そうするとすごく楽しいでしょ？友達が来て楽しいよ
違います 自分がつまらなかったんですよ
自分たちだけでもうみんなで毎日ワンパターンで
それで友達が訪ねた瞬間でワンパターンが潰れちゃいます
それで楽しみを感じるんです
それで特別な料理作ったり
みんな特別さ 今日はお母さん特別な料理作ってくれるんだからって子供たち舞い上がったりするんだけど
本当は前のパターンが潰れたことで楽しみを感じるんです
だからいつでも楽しみを感じるということはチェックしてみてください
過去のパターンが潰れちゃうんですね
それで楽しみを ですから無にあるんですよ
楽は サマージ状態を作る場合は有でサマージ状態やってみて
それ第四専行に行って
それから無でやっていただくと
これ大変なもう仕事で
でも決して悪いことじゃないんですよ
本当に厳密に真理の本物の楽に行くことだから
楽器を弾いて楽しむよりは
もう楽しむ場合は時空関係あるでしょうと
弾ける間はいいんでしょうし
楽器を弾けなくなっちゃうと
もう楽しみが消えちゃう
だから時空に 楽器は聞かんことで楽しめちゃうと
もういくらでも楽しめます
何もいらん 音を聞かないことが私にとっては音楽やと思ったら
もうそれが不動 だから不動という言葉は使うんです
時空関係 時空関係にそんなにやられませんね
じゃあそこら辺で終了します
それからこのヴィパッサナー瞑想の方にお釈迦様説明に持っていきます